翻訳: Naoko Hirami
校正: Hiroko Kawano
僕は楽しいことをするのが大好きです
大勢の人で いっぱいわいわい
みんなで一緒に楽しめる
そんな「外遊び」が大好きで
いろんなイベントを企画しています
そして 外遊びって 多分みなさん
いろいろ思いつくと思うんですけど
僕はその中で今日ひとつ
おすすめのものを紹介したいと思います
突然ですけど みなさん
「チャンバラ合戦IKUSA」って
ご存知でしょうか？
これねスポーツチャンバラとは
また違うんですよ
これは 僕が仲間と一緒に
オリジナルでルールも道具も考案した
新しい遊びです
ルールがこれまためっちゃ簡単なんですよ
左肩に「命」と呼ばれるこのボール
これは
このバンドにカチッとくっつくんですけど
これをこの右手に持ったスポンジの刀で落とす
これだけなんです
これを 例えば東軍と西軍に分かれて
二軍になって戦ったりしてるんですけど
ここまで説明すると大体の人が思うんです
「あぁ なるほど子供が楽しいやつね」と
思うんですよ
でもね ちょっと想像してみてください
大人 子供が入り混じる
200人の軍勢と軍勢が
昔合戦があった河川敷で
ほら貝の合図とともに
いっせいに真ん中に駆け寄りぶつかる
これどうなると思います？
めっちゃ楽しいんですよ これ（笑）
もうこれ 最高に楽しいんですよ（拍手）
もう大好きで 僕これが
またね 僕なにが言いたいかというと
大人も楽しいんですよ これ
この写真見てください
ほんま考えられへんぐらい
まぁまぁの大人がはしゃいでます
こんなチャンバラ合戦
特徴が今言ったとおり
ノーボーダー 誰でも参加できる
参加者を問わないということですね
子供が楽しい遊び 大人が楽しい遊び
多分 結構いっぱいあると思います
でも そこがフラットに一緒になって戦える
というのは
非常に特徴かなと思っています
というのも この命を 例えば壊したりとか
割ったりという風になってくると
やっぱり力が必要なんで
成人の男性が
やっぱり強くなると思うんですけど
チャンバラ合戦 これね 落とすだけです
これはクリーンヒットしたら必ず落ちます
つまり 力がいらないということで
子供や女性 そしてご年配の方でも
成人の男性と同じフィールドで
戦うことができる
なんやったら 勝つことが出来るというのが
このチャンバラ合戦IKUSAという
外遊びの最大の特徴です
ちなみに イベントのときに
毎回 今日一番強い奴決めようということで
個人戦やるんですけど
たいがい優勝するのが女性です
このチャンバラ合戦 多様な人ができます
今 下は3歳から
上は88歳のおじいちゃんまで参加してて
88歳のおじいちゃん すごいんです
はしゃぎすぎて 横の方で
孫 こんなんなってましたからね （笑）
「大丈夫 おじいちゃん？」
みたいな感じになって
あとですね 外国人の方でも
すぐ参加できるんですよね
というのが ルールが今言うたぐらい
非常にシンプルなんで
一回戦はずっと見てるんですよ
ほんで「参加する？」と言ったら
「All right」とすぐ入ってくるんですよ
外国人でも入れる そんなユニバーサルな
エンターテイメントであるというのが
このチャンバラ合戦の最大の特徴です
ルールはシンプルなんですけど
これだけ多様な人が一緒に楽しもうと思うと
やっぱり一応禁止事項は 作っているんです
ただ この禁止事項もシンプルでないといけない
僕ら一言で表しています
「武士道に反する行為はすべて禁止」
という風に言っています（笑）
これどういうことかというと
例えば転んでる相手に容赦なく切りかかるとか
命以外のところ 顔とかに攻撃する
スポンジなので痛くないんですけど
無駄なところに攻撃
これも格好悪いんで全部やめてください
という風にしています
後はですね 例えば大人の方で多いんですけど
命がそんなに惜しいかっていうぐらい
こうやって戦う人がおるんですね（笑）
これもう 子供さんが
どういう目で見てるかって話ですよ
また一番最悪なんがね
命落ちたんを「しれーっ」と付け直す（笑）
人知を超えた神への冒涜行為のようなこと
（笑）
「しれーっ」と
まだそのまま参加してくるという
刀を持った時点で みんな侍
一人の侍として僕は扱って
武士道に反する行為をした人みんな禁止
すべて退場していただいている
というルールでやらせてもらっています
で いろんな合戦を開催させてもらってます
そのときにいろいろ珍事件が起きているので
IKUSA語録というのを僕ら作っているので
紹介させてもらいたいと思います
こないだ 森の中でやったんですね
「森林戦」ってやったんですけど
障害物わさわさなんですよ
「敵 見えへん 」みたいな
で 戦術が立てれるので 楽しいんですけど
木があって 草あって こうやっていて
さぁ行くぞ 「ふぁさ」といって
落ちたんですね（笑）
あと 写真見てもらったらわかるんですけど
ものすごい隅に追いやられたら
「味方と距離近い近い」
みたいな感じで
「ばさー」とぶつかって落ちたりするんです
これどうなるか？
僕ら 「自害」と呼んで
全部アウトにしています（笑）
あとですね 最近あったんですけど
百貨店の屋上でやらせてもらった時に
20人ぐらいの小規模な合戦だったんです
二軍に分かれて 最後ね
大人と子供の一騎打ちになったんですよ
大人の方 そりゃやっぱ
子供に花持たせてあげたいでしょ
こんな感じで戦っていたんですね
普通 こうなんです
右手[に] 刀なんで
でもね あきらかに「取ってよ 早く」という
感じなんですけど
この子供それまで
めっちゃ強かったんですけど
なんでか知らんけど １対１になって
めっちゃ戦い雑[に]なったんですよ
全然当たらへん
全然当たらへん戦いが１分 ２分と過ぎて
もう大人限界やったんでしょうね 体力が
もう最後の最後「君の勝ちや！」と言って
（笑）
これ僕ら「切腹」と呼んで（笑）
武士として最高に格好いい行為として
賞賛の拍手を送るという
そんな出来事がありました
こんなチャンバラ合戦を 僕ら今
日本全国で開催させてもらっています
色んな行政や自治体とコラボをして
例えば 地域のお祭りだったり
戦国がテーマのフェスティバルだったり
そういった所で
開催させて頂いているんですけど
もちろん土地土地によって
歴史やいろんな物語が違ってくるので
いろんな種類の戦いがあります
ちょっとユニークだったものを
お知らせします
滋賀県であった「浅井あっぱれ祭」を
ご存知の方いらっしゃいますかね？
「よさこいソーラン」の全国大会みたいな
戦いなんですけど
見てわかるとおり日本中から
テンション高いやつ
めちゃくちゃ集まるんですよ
またしかも 服もかっこいいでしょ？
もうめっちゃみんな元気あふれてね
このテンションのままチャンバラ合戦やるので
チャンバラ合戦[は]MCが
「戦 開始」と言ったら
参加者は刀[を持って]
「オー！」って始まるんですけど
「戦 か」ぐらいで
もうこの状態になっています（笑）
基本的にMCの言うこと聞かないという
この「浅井あっぱれ祭り」の特徴なんですけど
で その一番テンション高い人たちの
最前列にいるのが
僕が大好きなよさこいチームなんですけど
北海道大学の「縁」っていうチームがあって
みんな礼儀正しくて元気良くて
僕大好きなチームなんですけど
一番最初にいきなり走り出すから
一番すぐ負けるんですよ
で その反省の意味をこめてか
わかんないんですけど
IKUSA終わった後
いつも切腹の儀式をするという
これ僕は「浅井あっぱれ」で
隠れ名物やと思っているのですけど
こんな愉快な人たちとの
出会いがあったりですとか
あと 例えばいろんなフェスティバルの中で
やらしてもらうときは
そこの土地の将軍の名前をつけて
何々軍とかテーマが決まってるんですけど
自分たちで 例えば 体育館を取ったり
場所を押さえたりして開催するときは
好きにテーマを設定することができるので
結構いろんな企画をやっています
で 最近好評だった企画が
「逃走中」という企画をやりました
これ「キラープレイヤー」
というのですけど
命をつけずにフィールドを走り回るという
とんでもない恐ろしいキャラなんですね
その時は 10人ずつぐらいの
少数のユニットを何十チームも作って
その中に彼らを解き放つという
めっちゃ走ってくるんですね
とんでもなく怖いんです
でもね 追いかけられたらわかるんです
これがまためっちゃ楽しいんですよ
この時にめっちゃ満足度が
アンケートで高かったのです
めっちゃ好評だったんですけど
唯一最大の反省点が一点
「キラープレイヤー」ね
もちろん無表情なんです
最後まで殺戮マシンでいようと言ってたのに
運営メンバーの一人[が]写真で楽しくなって
ほくそえんでまうっていう（笑）
しかもその瞬間を写真に押さえられるという
（笑）
運営メンバーも楽しんでしまうという
こういうことがありました
このチャンバラ合戦を 今 仲間と一緒に
だいたい４年ぐらい
やらしてもらってるんですけど
最初は楽しいからやってたんです
もうそれ以外 それ以上でも以下でもない
楽しい みんなと一緒に笑顔になれる
この楽しい場をいっぱい増やしたい
というのでやっていたのですけど
やっぱ回数重ねていくと
すごい色んなことに気がつき始めます
で その中で今日お話したいのが
「遊びの価値」です
でも 遊びの価値ってなんだと思います？
僕で言う「外遊びの価値」になるんですけど
広いフィールドで走り回って
心が開放的になるとか
リフレッシュできるとか
あとは団体戦なのでこう 団結力
団結を感じることが出来る
チーム力を感じることができる
また 非日常体験を通じて 刺激を得れる
あんな奴に追いかけられること
まずないですからね
非日常体験で 刺激になる
といろいろあると思うんですけど
僕が一番この外遊び
遊びの価値として思うのが
大人が心の鎧を脱ぐ機会として
価値があるんじゃないかな？
という風に思っています
人は社会的な生き物なので
日々 自分にいろんな制約をかけて
毎日を生きています
ときに自分を守るために
いっぱいいっぱい鎧をつけて
毎日生きてると思います
どえらい分厚い兜をつけている人も
多分いると思うんですよ
それは社会が回るために多分必要なものです
でも この必要なものを
たまにはやっぱりとらないと
精神衛生上すごく良くないんじゃないかな？
と思います
特にやっぱ現代人 特に日本人は
労働時間も長いですし 休日も少ない
この心の鎧を脱ぐ機会ってのが
なかなかないと思うんですね
僕なんかでもすごい仕事が忙しくなってくると
脱ぐタイミングもわからへんし
なんやったら たまに脱ぎ方忘れた
みたいな時もあるぐらい
やっぱり追い込まれて
毎日自分に制約を加えて
現代人は生きていると思うんです
そんな人に
このチャンバラ合戦をはじめとする
外遊びというものを ちょっと
ぜひ活用していただきたいなという風に
思っています
そして遊びというものは 今まで
勉強や仕事といった
絶対しないといけないものの
真反対の対角のもの 無駄なものとして
捉えられてきたと思います
でもこれからの世の中では
果たしてそうなんでしょうか？
本当にこれは無駄なものなんでしょうか？
僕は「ノー」だと思います
その理由は
この遊びの価値というものの向こう側に
僕はさらなる大きな可能性を
感じているからです
遊びを通じて心の鎧を脱ぐことが出来ます
そしてその心に鎧が入っていた分だけ
脱いだ分
ちょっとだけ心に隙間ができるんですよね
心の余裕と言ってもいいかもしれません
心に遊びが持てるっていう言い方も
いいかもしれません
その隙間に僕は価値があると思っています
今から世の中は加速度的に
多様化が進んでいきます
僕らの周りには見たこともない
考えられないような
多彩な考え方やアイデアがあふれかえって
わけわからなくなります
そのときに
新しい物を自分の中に取り入れる
そのための準備として
その隙間というのは すごいたくさんの
可能性 価値を持っているんだと
僕は思っています
その隙間を作るための遊び
これは非常に価値があるもの
ではないでしょうか？
僕は思っています
「Dive into Diversity」
今回のTEDxKobeのテーマです
でも果たしてダイブしていく先の未来は
もう既ににそこにあるものとして
捉えていいんでしょうか？
僕はもう少し考えるべきかなと思います
ダイブしていくと同時に
先の未来も作っていくという意識が
必要なのではないでしょうか？
僕はどうせ飛び込んでいくのだったら
多彩な人がいろんな価値観や考え方が
混在しているだけの世の中よりも
多様な人がお互いを認め合い 共存している
そんな世界にダイブしていきたい
そのためには これからも
心の隙間を作るための機会として
遊びという場をいろんな場で
たくさんの人を巻き込んで
楽しく作っていきたいと思っています
これからもこの活動を続けていきます
ということで
今日この場にいる人たちに
最後このメッセージを送って
終わりにしたいと思います
ぜひみなさん今日ここでお会いできたのも
なにかのご縁です
ぜひ一緒に遊びましょう！
ありがとうございました
（拍手）